[Music]
[Applause]
is that one of my favorite people
to work with in the world is standing by
and ready to talk about the death of the
super
league my friend robbie earl from nbc
sports our premier league coverage
robbie good to see your uh your smiling
face robbie you and i
shared a studio together when the news
was breaking we heard in our ears we're
like
adam told us he said hey this seems kind
of big this this seems like this could
be a thing
take us take us back there and your
thoughts when you were hearing of
this super league becoming a reality let
me know
let me tell you when i knew we were in
for a big day when adam said
now here rip up the running order
it's a blank cage we start from here and
every five minutes
the picture was changing it was a fluid
situation um
just to maybe explain uh obviously you
know maybe some of some of our viewers
uh in terms of where football stands in
the uk
i mean it is the game it's football and
everything else
in terms of sport comes a very big
second it's nfl it's nba it's
nhl it's major league baseball all
rolled into one so
when the thought of six team owners
at the six biggest clubs we're going to
take their
group and create a european super league
which basically meant it was a boys only
club where
there was no promotion and relegation
they'd invite three or four teams in a
year to come and play with us but
basically it was their league
they were gonna run it and the rest of
english football was in jeopardy
the interest of english football is the
football is a premier league that
everybody knows but there's a pyramid
below that armor that goes
through thousands of people to thousands
of teams
and basically the premier league clubs
that move away
are almost spelling the death knell to
those teams and so this was huge
it was seismic it in football it's one
of those huge days in football on
tuesday
the 20th of april 2021
was the day when english football said
you're not taking it
you may be the wealthy owners of six
clubs but this is our game and we're
grabbing the game back and fans went out
and government got involved in the royal
family got involved in players and
coaches and managers
and it was very obvious that the six
ownership groups had not taken into
consideration the temperature
of what this would do to english
football and very quickly
we saw we call them the dirty dozen the
12 teams six from england
three from spain and three from italy
who were gonna go together and form this
european super league very
quickly one by one they started to fall
out and um
it was a huge day for english football
and a huge day to show where the power
of the fan stands yeah i explain it to
people i use the analogy
robbie of like college basketball and
you have right now some blue blood
uh blue blood teams like kentucky kansas
you got michigan state
duke north carolina it'd be like if they
all were in their conferences still
competing for acc big ten
titles but instead of going to the ncaa
tournament anymore which is the
champions league they just said we're
not doing that anymore we're making our
own tournament
we're going to be in it every year and
we'll let in three other
cinderella teams uh and that would not
have flown here
this did not fly over in europe so
what was your biggest fear if this had
gone through
robbie would was it possible that
everything we know about football and
everything that people in england
know and love about it would have gone
away
i'll give you my personal view first
that the dream i had it seven or eight
years of age when
people would say to me oh what do you
want to be when you grow up and i'd say
a footballer
and they tap me on my head and say oh
that's really nice
that dream would have been gone for
every kid in the uk there would be no
way that the structures
and the platforms would be in place that
i could go from an academy
to a young professional team to a team
to get to premier league to play
international football
that would have been gone because six
owners wanted to take the all that's
good about english football and create
this european super
super league beyond that every league
below the premier league
and in england these many leagues like
minor leagues maybe in the us that
that rely on money that's trickled down
basically these clubs going away
takes that trickle down with them so the
premier league would be different
the these clubs would maybe still want
you to play in the premier league but
that wouldn't have been that their main
aim because
they're already going into their super
competition they don't have to finish
top four so the premier league they
could play average teams in the premier
league and save all their big guns all
their big players for
the super league that so the the premier
league would be different the
relegation and promotion the opportunity
for teams like bournemouth
to come from the lowest league in
english football and hold their own in
in the premier league there'd be no
leicester cities who were one
season in the third tier of english
football some six seven years later
going on to win the premier league i
mean those dreams those stories
that that drama that is a premier league
would have been no more
one of the big story lines robbie was
people were saying that this was the
americanization
or at least that was the attempt of the
game in
england and europe because you had
american owners of some of these big
clubs that were a big part
of creating a super league yeah do you
think that
we'll ever see another american owner be
able to come in take control of one of
these big clubs uh
again in england or is there going to be
a lot of reticence it's a really
interesting point
and the americanism is i thought
not totally true because these things
about a european breakaway have been
going arm it for
15 or 20 years there's always been a
thought that at some point
those big clubs playing on a regular
basis should be what happens now
that is generally the moment the
champions league and there is no doubt
what what's happened in the game and
these six clubs trying to pull away
is waking everybody up to saying we need
to look at the structure of football we
need to look that we can get
you know the big clubs should be able to
play at times and maybe earn a little
bit more
more money because they are the big
clubs they're the driver but they also
need the
little clubs as well they need the
premier league and they should be part
of that
i think what will change in your right
is maybe i think there'll be rules and
regulations in terms of ownership of
football clubs i don't think we'll
ever get back to this stage where one
single owner will have the up the
ability
to take a club into a league
or into another continent or another
region
it's not beneficial it's not that
anybody else within that league cannot
have a say over um
they do it in germany it's a 50 plus one
there where i think the fans have
uh some ownership in in a club where the
fans have a say
i wouldn't be surprised if some form of
that is replicated in england because
the fans have spoken on this and
um they certainly deserve a say so real
madrid's president
florentino perez has come out and said
the super league is on standby which is
what happens when everyone drops out of
it you got to put it on standby
but he's still robbie blasted the
current champions league system as
his words obsolete said there's waning
support from young people
things need to change so this is not
going to happen
in its form do you think there's still a
possibility
that something may be like this with
other considerations
is there still change possible
in european football yes and there
should be
um i don't particularly agree with all
that he said but i do feel that
the structure of the champions league
can be looked at
as long as the leicester cities of the
world who win the premier league
go into that competition with every
chance of winning that as well
as long as there's the ability that it's
not a closed shot where there's not
found the members where there's not been
run by the the people with the big money
then i i believe there is room for
conversation and and what
what pleases me out of what come out of
tuesday
when the team started to fall away is
that when those teams sit around a table
now
it's a whole different conversation at
one time they sat around the table as if
to say
yes you're in our company but but we're
really the big boys
will tell you what's happening now i
think it's taking a little bit away from
them
and they have to come to the table not
capping hand but certainly
on it on a more level basis and have a
discussion that's for the better of
football
as well as the better of these six clubs
all right so for
talking about perhaps some changes down
the road my last one here
robbie okay would there ever be
a premier league team in america
could that ever work where an american
team
say in new york could get a team
together
and become part of the english football
pyramid i think not i
i think what we saw in terms of numbers
and fans
and people it was always rumored that
back in england
sort of the early days of the premier
league about maybe playing one premier
league game
overseas and the kind of scenes we saw
when six
owners thought they could take the
league away would be a similar thing
english football is very proud of what
it does and how it does and how it
markets it and
and how it sells it and i think teams
coming over and playing
you know tournament games and friendly
games and things in the summer's fine
but in terms of the premier league and
where it's played i think we will
we will generally see it played on on uk
shores immediately shot down
my dream just like that story my friend
robbie earl the other way is we have to
travel over to england to go and watch
games and report on games
in that way we can always we can always
have a good pint of english beer
oh robbie always great working with you
you're interesting
you're awesome thanks for joining us all
right we'll see you have a good day
enjoy